good evening ladies and gentlemen I met
so soprano Julie Nasrallah and host of
tempo on CBC Radio to welcome and thank
you all for coming this evening will not
only be full of wonderful music it will
also be full of exciting scientific
ideas about how and why you experience
music the way you do you will look at
the neurology behind your experience of
music and even explore the idea that it
is fundamental to making us human I hope
you enjoyed the Griffin trios opening
piece but why did you enjoy it well one
possible answer is that it's a marvelous
work performed by masterful musicians
however there is another way of looking
at it you all SAT here for five minutes
listening to a collection of sounds of
different timbres being played at
varying pitches organized around a
particular rhythm but there are no words
there were no pictures there are no
symbols at all that you would normally
use for conveying meaning yet those
sounds gave you pleasure in fact music
goes further than just giving pleasure
it can invoke images and sensations and
deep emotions such as sadness joy and
awe how and why does this happen I
remember the thrill I had the first time
I heard Beethoven's fifth symphony
during the transition from the 3rd to
the 4th movement it's very dramatic I
heard it while on a school trip to see
the movie fame in the theater and I
remember feeling overwhelmed with a
surge of excitement and Wonder and magic
Beethoven was rocking my little soul and
I looked around the dark theater to see
if any of the other kids were wide-eyed
and filled with oh my god did that just
rock your world too well if the other
kids were loving it they didn't show it
so I kept my passion for Beethoven to
myself and it's a passion that has grown
strong for me over the years I have the
exact same passion for Van Morrison a
couple of years ago I flew to Belfast
alone to hear
him play an exclusive concert for 200
people there's just something about the
sound of his voice that feels like home
to me and I I don't know why every human
society that we have ever known has had
some sort of music and the evidence for
music extends as long ago as 35,000
years the approximate age of ancient
bone flutes discovered by archaeologists
Charles Darwin himself the father of
evolutionary theory puzzled over why
humans should have a capacity for music
he suggested music might have developed
as a courtship ritual and that singing
actually led to language other
scientists think that our musical
ability began with the need to pay
attention to natural rhythms or that it
helped us survive by strengthening
social bonds tonight you'll hear from
two leading scientists about their
research into the neural underpinnings
of the brains response to music they
will be aided by the great gryphon trio
and by you you all received clickers
upon entering the hall this evening the
clickers are very easy to use you press
the number or the letter on the clicker
that corresponds to your choice on the
screen so for the questions with
multiple answers you can press or change
your response as many times as you want
it will only record your last vote the
researchers will hear from tonight are
with the azrieli program in brain mind
and consciousness at sea far the
Canadian Institute for Advanced Research
see far is a Canadian research
institution that brings together the
best researchers from around the globe
to work on complex questions of
importance to the world the azrieli
program in brain mind and consciousness
is bringing the best minds together to
explore questions of consciousness and
the brain earlier tonight see far
announced that the azrieli foundation
has given the extraordinarily generous
gift of ten million dollars to make the
program possible
on behalf of CPR please join me in
thanking the Israeli foundation for this
visionary gift